remember what was the point of doing all
of these prime numbers right the whole
point is that we want what the prime
numbers are because they're useful
they're useful to encryption okay so
it's kind of interesting to know how
many Prime's there are but what I really
want to know is well what the primes
okay because then I can use them so
there are two main ways to techniques
for how to get Prime's okay the first
method is called a sieve right and
there's a whole bunch of series and the
second method is called
a generator okay I'm just going to show
you one sieve and then I'm going to show
you a pair of generators but there's a
whole bunch of these okay because this
problem is interesting and valuable and
useful lots of people have worked out
ways to solve it so what I'm going to
show you is the sieve of this ancient
Greek guy named Eratosthenes very very
awkward named Eratosthenes you want to
know how to pronounce it it's era
so the sieve of Eratosthenes how does it
work how does SIB work or maybe I should
ask what does a sieve do anyone who
bakes anyone
what does ICF do good good so it's it
separates out right you've got your
flour your pour it in okay
and as you shake the sieve what happens
yeah well okay what falls through it
breaks things out right and it lets
through what is small enough to fit
through the sieve do you know these fine
little holes here and actually some
things are left behind there will be
some really really big chunks of flour
that are stuck and then all of the
little ones will fall through so the
silver Eratosthenes ulcers actually what
they'll do is they'll sift out all the
composite numbers and they will leave
you with just the primes okay so here's
the way it works I mean the thing that
you need to know to do this is what's
the first prime number okay after that
the whole thing just unfolded stuff so
the first prime number of course is 2
okay so we know what he is you can
ignore one poor one
here's the way the sieve works I'm gonna
cross out every second number okay all
the multiples of two okay and then I'm
gonna go through so much right I've got
a two here so I crossed out four six
eight ten and so on
okay so crossing out all the way down so
I'm crossing out all the multiples of
two okay so now what's left well the
next number that wasn't crossed out its
prime and that's three okay that's what
the sieve tells you okay a shape a rook
shakin shakin the sin okay and I've I've
got one number has made it out now I use
this number and I cross out all the
multiples of three of course some of
them or it even crossed out but you can
see which ones haven't there's a nine
okay all right good so I've crossed out
all the multiples of three and so now I
look and I see another numbers made it
through the sieve namely five that's the
next one okay the multiples of five are
quite easy to get rid of out that 15 20
25 30 35 40 25 already gone so now I've
got my next prime number there he is so
now I cross out all of his multiples and
it looks like what am I go left
49 way to I already cross that 42 my
first pass okay so then you have a look
okay now I'll let you have a think about
this see 11 how many multiples of 11 are
left behind they've all actually gone
already they're all going out there 22s
: 33 is gone with 3 44 is even and 55
doesn't make it so in fact once I've
gotten to 7 I wonder if you can work out
why is it seven there's a reason why let
you try and work it out okay once I've
got to seven everything left is prime
the Civic is finished okay so now I can
take up to three five seven eleven
thirteen I've got them all there we go
see I had that one already forty-seven
there you go
the city's done